culinary genius our five contestants are
about to put themselves through a
cooking ordeal that will take them way
beyond their comfort zone these five
hopeful cooks are ready and waiting to
do culinary battle now they've each
brought their favorite item from their
home kitchen to help them today and
ready to judge that every step of the
way is our wonderful head chef whose
creativity in the kitchen is second to
none Edward Lee so much fun to have
today what do you have in store for our
contestants all right so today we're
gonna start with a simple challenge to
test your culinary knowledge the three
cooks who perform the best get to move
on to the cook-off
so let's reveal what's in store for
round one contestants please lift your
cloches it's Peppers now before Edward
reveals the details of today's challenge
here is the most fiery chef in the
business it's Gordon Ramsay right today
you get to work with these bad boys the
most amazing Chili's America consumes on
average two point three billion chilies
a year that's a lot quick tip if you
happen to bite into a chili that's so
hot don't drink water take a sip of milk
that will cool the heat down now there
are some chilies that are grown in
Trinidad that have been known to burn
through the farmers gloves Wow what
would I do with these I turn them into
the most amazing chili jam and serve
that with grilled fish or meat right
Edward it's time to turn the heat up in
the studio thanks Gordon today cooks you
must determine the heat rating of 6
peppers and place them on your board in
the order of their Heat
you've been provided with a knife and a
glass of milk so feel free to taste the
peppers but at your peril the three
cooks replace the most peppers correctly
will go through to round 2 good luck
okay our cooks know what they have to do
but how well can they handle the heat
contestants you have just two minutes of
the battle begin obviously so many
different types of peppers how is the
hotness measured so Scoville unit is a
measure of heat all right so the higher
the Scoville unit the hotter the pepper
the key is to try and start by tasting
what you think is the mildest pepper
because if you start with the hottest
pepper guess what you're gonna burn your
tongue and you really can't taste
anything after that
right okay well let's check in on them
[Music]
Brandon from way back here I can tell
your eyes are watering guys it's a good
hurt it's a good panty so you you would
like to eat a lot of spicy food yeah I
love it
h1 foods very spicy kind of Asian style
and kind of go the other side of the
world you know there's lots of great hot
sauces out there all right hey black how
you doing feel pretty good I think
there's a jalapeno red chili okay not
too sure about these two I'm pretty sure
that's a habanero so it's gotta be on
the top of the scale for the two and
then I'm just gonna try to taste the
rest good luck thank you
Trudy already everything's all lined up
do you cook with peppers a lot I do cook
with some but I am a bit of a wolf in
the daughter Nancy love it every time I
ever ate anything spicy was when I was
pregnant
take your final moment I'll leave you
two I do thank you
Eva are you going to be confident with
these peppers you know where they're
going
I think so I think the smaller the
hunter are you gonna try every one maybe
okay thank you
Karen already sliced and diced some of
these yes I feel pretty confident I've
only had one sip and milk okay what did
what did you taste this one here it's
the seeds that really give the most half
turn right here with the seats I think
that's what it was Trudy and Brandon
seem to have their stuff together if
it's in the right order but they're
definitely getting them on the board
Aaden seems pretty confident though he
only has two peppers right now on the
board he's got to pick it up 30 seconds
just 30 seconds left put your final
placement on the scale ed what is your
favorite way to cook with peppers well
so I have two favorite things I love to
do I love to pickle them with some
vinegar salt it just makes a beautiful
condiment the other that's great is to
sauté them with aromatics and vegetables
and pureed to make a really lovely fiery
hot sauce
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hard from the start for our five
contestants but only three can go
through to the final and it's time to
find out from Edward how they should
have done now to show you how a hardcore
chef does this I'm gonna taste every
pepper before I describe this Aidan I
need you to do me a favor
yep take this glass of milk no matter
how I cry do not let me have it first
one I'm gonna start with is the padrone
it's the mildest pepper of the bunch at
2,500 Scoville units we've got a little
bit of a kick they're really nice grill
toss a little bit of olive oil and salt
next up we have the jalapeno hmm really
fruity really beautiful the cayenne
pepper kicks up a knot 50,000 Scoville
units you're probably more familiar with
the dried version of the cayenne next up
serenaded it has a nice warm ruby flavor
oh this has got a seat in and now you
know the seed is where all the capsaicin
is that's the spice so when you eat a
seed it's gonna be a lot hotter than
just eating the flesh this is a Thai
chili at 225,000 Scoville units we start
to really feel burned last but not least
we have our scotch bonnet this is
350,000 Scoville units
it's really hot but it also has a really
nice fragrant citrus flavor too so when
you're cooking with it if you can figure
out a way to balance the heat you're
actually gonna get the most fruity
flavor out of that pepper it's a really
beautiful pepper to work with all right
back to your stations
Eva I don't know what to say but you
know you try you got the tempers in
somewhere obviously you got the hot and
the mild one you know in between you had
a little trouble there but but you know
where your extremes are yeah yeah not
bad I'm seeing a lot of things in my
place as a couple that yeah I think you
got mixed up on you should've tasted
more but not bad you got sort of the
spicier spectrum
so we'll see how you do on the lower end
of it well shaky you got kind of
confused I don't think peppers are a
very good friend of yours but yeah it
looked pretty on the plate make new
friends all right at over time for you
to tell us which three of our
contestants will be going through to the
final the first contestant going through
to the final with the score of four out
of six is Brandon with the score three
out of six is Trudy the third and final
contestant to go through with a score of
six
[Applause]
Brandon Trudy and Aiden you are going
through to the final cook-off round the
competition ends right here for both
Karen and Eva who scored zero so our
remaining three contestants have fought
off the competition and their final
battle is looming they have been given
today's protein which is skirt steak
that's right now they must use it with
at least one of the peppers from round
one to produce a genius dish worthy of a
winner so Edward what are you looking
for from our three finalists here today
I don't want just abominable hot food I
want something that's balanced artful
beautiful I want something that's genius
the pantry will be open for just two
minutes in that two minutes you guys can
grab as much as you want your time
starts now
[Applause]
chef's what do we have in the pantry
today there are soba noodles sweet
potato
there's beets cilantro and tamarind
concentrate Brandon leave some for
others I'm grabbing as much as I can
there's so many options here the more
the merrier listen guys don't just
randomly grab everything think about the
dish you want to make okay I'm sort of
just grabbing anything I'm sort of torn
between two dishes and don't forget I
want pretty artful plates I want
something that looks like I can eat it
at a restaurant
[Music]
25 minutes to make that winning dish so
let the final battle begin hello hater
what did you grab from the pantry got
some beet greens some chickpeas so which
are the peppers that you're you know how
to use the jalapenos and take the ochre
and I'm gonna make a green Verde salsa
and I'm gonna plant these beetroot
collard greens and we'll see where we go
for a long time obviously I mean I think
it best cooker of beef but I think
cooking is an art form and so the
flavors will speak to them so hopefully
Brandon you had a lot of goodies what
are you gonna do I'm gonna hit this with
five-spice and then create a little
barbecue sauce you cooked a little bit
some of the chilies well let's watch I
brought over today mr. Rottier brought
from home yes
so these Chili Peppers um I'm gonna try
to probably use a little both and I'm
gonna probably go with this guy maybe a
little bit the birds eye's well I think
I've been in corporate peppers in a good
way with the meat and it's definitely
shine through 20 minutes cooks
hey there Trudy like that Oh what you
did grab from the pan all right I'm
going to use the red wine opposed to
remaining sauce with shallots and garlic
and then just touch it with some French
peas
okay what pepper you're gonna use this
is the yes the cayenne tip on the spy
stuff taste as you go it's really
important yes I don't want something
that's gonna burn the roof of my mouth
exactly
I'd work I know you like things spicy
what would you have picked the pantry
today you know what I'm not gonna go for
the spices but I definitely would have
gone for the Thai Chili's you make a
nice marinade let that skirt steak sit
in that marinade to live the very last
minute grill it up hot slice it then put
a little puree on it some vegetables
maybe some fresh tomatoes beautiful Aden
has a lot going on and then of course
he's vegetarian he doesn't usually cook
with me to me it seems like he's
basically making a salad and I'm putting
big into it so I want to make sure that
he's actually incorporating beef in a
meaningful way that it's not just kind
of thrown in there because he needs to -
Brandon here anything listen he's got a
lot of stuff going on you know he pretty
much took the whole pantry so he's got
everything at its discovered what I
don't want to see him do is sort of get
overly anxious and used everything that
he go because then you're just gonna
have confusion on a plate he's making
steak with a mustard mashed potatoes red
wine sauce over that is this shallots
being thrown in she seems to have kind
of more with a classical French dish
going on it's hard to incorporate spicy
peppers into that no she quite thought
about it when she was at the pantry but
she found ingredients like yellow
mustard balsamic vinegar these aren't
the things that would have come up in my
mind when I was trying to pair with
chili peppers for over half wait
meaning cooks are desperate to prove to
Edward Lee that they deserve the title
culinary genius so let's see how they're
doing all right hi there everything I
know that you are a brand manager so
does that mean that you really know
about presentation I think I know how to
sell things in a marketing perspective
what would it mean to be named culinary
genius it would mean a lot you know
cooking is my life my mother is probably
five years ago no shima paraplegic and
with I became the sole cook in the house
you know so I know I miss this today is
definitely for her I wish you good luck
yeah Cheers
we're at seven minutes seven minutes
hello Aidan what does your girlfriend
windows in the audience today think of
your cooking oh she's a vegetarian too
so it's a cake how are his vegetarian
dishes really good he tends to when he
uses spice it's very spicy so so he's
okay with the peppers yeah so very low
your socks fair enough and your tasting
which is good because Edward likes when
you do that so well done there all right
thank you good luck hello there Trudy
smell fantastic over here what would it
mean to you to win
thousand dollars on sort of duty with my
mother she's got two men to reclaim its
head be quite nice to just take my
husband and daughter on holiday like an
old break
just that we're nice and hot all right
Trudy good luck thank you all right
cooks time's running out get those
steaks down please I don't want raw meat
Brandon how you do it well all right
listen I saw you put your sriracha in
there you didn't make your own I did but
I incorporated the peppers in the
marinade for the steak having trouble
mashing in your minute potatoes on
or that's probably not the best idea
yeah let's go I need food in the plant I
made something beautiful and I need that
slice yes yep
Judy I want spice we're gonna give me
some spikes we're gonna give you some
flavor we gotta hurry up time's running
out two and a half minutes left
think about presentation I want
beautiful beautiful plates a tin what
are you doing what you did
the cashew cream that's cool down
and I got my green berry sauce you got
your cool but where's your heat yeah
right this all right bring me some heat
of panthus good luck man it's a mess
down there it is a message absolute
chaos
I got Brandon trying to mashed potatoes
on a cutting board please if it's not on
the plate I can't judge it part of
culinary genius where it is time for
Edward to judge our finalists steak
dishes
I'll even cook beef in 810 years and I
don't regularly cook I don't eat it so I
hope it will impress the chef's I think
it's maybe a little under from what the
chef likes but we'll see I don't tend to
eat meat like that really it would still
alive and I'm sure it'd be fine
hope for the best this looks all nice I
saw you had a million vegetables out
there I'm glad to see then it kind of
went into one unified focused dish I
will say your steak a little bit on the
rare side but well let's go in a bit
this one taste it thicker cut of meat
that I had was done mm-hmm too late now
all right Aiden listen you made a pretty
nice dish the beet loot please I thought
were a little bland undersalted and
being a chili pepper competition I wish
there was more heat because I wanted
that fire yeah all right however that
salsa verde is beautiful I love that you
put that Oprah in there to combine
everything and that cashew sauce is
absolute gold in fact I want the recipe
to that because I'm stealing it I would
never have eaten this and thought a
vegetarian made this they loved the beet
and potato combination you under boil
those potatoes so obviously you couldn't
get a match down properly your steak is
obviously on the rare side yeah but
let's go in for the taste your barbecue
sauce is really nice it's got sort of
this like initial garlic and then it
creeps up on you the heat and it's a
really nice kind of delayed heat
reaction you have this kind of really
lovely beef going on and then you've got
almost a waxy raw potato and then the
beet as well almost tastes like a salad
because it's so raw
yeah overall though I love it it's just
the veggies on the bottom that really
didn't work first of all I'm gonna tell
you you gave me an entire cow in a plate
I know it's a lot of meat yeah like an
attempt I can already see that it's
rockered so I'm gonna cut into the
middle and see how raw it is okay all
right we're gonna go in for this and
yeah it's raw I'm going to pull a little
piece off the end here because I think
this piece is a little bit more Cup
this pepper thing I love it you know
it's got bell peppers so you think it's
not really spicy and then you got the
sweet from the balsamic and then the
kind of spice kind of builds on you it's
really nice what I would do you can put
the peppers over the meal right yeah you
know you could have sliced it super thin
put it on the plate serve it cold and
just tell me it's the tataki welcome
poncho yeah the same thing it's it's not
a bad plate of food
it's time to find out who Edward has
chosen to reveal today's winner
finalists please lift your cloches
[Applause]
we'll put you over the top was you not
only have one but two amazing salsas and
that was James
[Applause]